this is lucy james reading for reviewer
alessandro barbossa there is little to
question that diablo immortal is a big
and richly produced diablo entry it
looks great it involves the formula of
action role playing introduced in diablo
3 and matches it acutely to the hardware
it was originally designed for and it
strikes a good balance of making you
feel powerful while also enticing you to
continue hunting down better loot in
that sense diablo immortal is just
another good diablo game but it's also
one that can't always be played with the
same obsessive cadence as prior titles
given the number of barriers that can
routinely force some time away from it
the story takes place between diablo 2
and 3 with familiar faces popping up to
provide some thin context for events
that have transpired by the time you
arrive in tristram at the start of the
last core title there you are
come
stay awhile
deckard kane is back and why wouldn't he
be and so is a new evil that is
threatening to use shards of the same
world stone to wreak havoc across the
lands story conversations are fully
voiced which makes immortal feel as
premium as previous diablo titles on pc
there's really nothing here that
suggests it's anything less than that
either with large open spaces for you to
explore and numerous side quests to
undertake as you progress through the
story
what is different is obviously where
you'll be playing diablo immortal was
designed for smartphones and it's
unsurprising then that it plays best on
them too the touch controls employ the
familiar digital analog stick on the
left hand side of the screen while the
right features a cluster of buttons for
your various abilities you have a single
main attack along with four equippable
skills to choose from with a fifth
ultimate ability button appearing once
you have access to it it's simple and
well spaced out and i never found myself
accidentally pressing any skills i
didn't want to you can move and have
attacks target enemies automatically
which simplifies your focus further but
also helps you accurately aim certain
skills that require it with my
necromancer i often need to choose the
area in which i want to explode a bunch
of corpses which is easily done by just
holding down the skill in question and
rotating my finger to position it in a
chaotic fight where i needed to pull
this off fast the accuracy could be a
little wonky but these moments were
mostly fleeting diablo immortal also
supports a variety of controllers that
you compare using bluetooth and here the
action becomes even more manageable with
a physical stick movement is more
natural and mapping abilities to buttons
and triggers meant it was even rarer for
mistakes to crop up better yet the right
stick can be used to aim abilities
removing the need to have a single tap
perform double duty still it wasn't as
significant a difference that i found
myself always ensuring i had a
controller on hand if i wanted to play
diablo immortal on the go diablo
immortal is also supported on pc albeit
under an open beta banner that is well
deserved the game on pc is disappointing
to say the least missing many basic
features expected of a pc game that make
it a far worse way to play the game
while many of the game's visual settings
can still be toggled on and off from the
mobile versions including levels of
detail and maximum frame rates the pc
version can only be played at 1080p
though it's still the most popular
resolution amongst pc players it's
unacceptable to have a pc version out
that doesn't let you change this setting
making ui elements and text look blown
out and blurry at anything other than
its native resolution it's clear at this
time at least the diablo immortal was
developed primarily for mobile and thus
you should probably stick to playing it
there gameplay has been tweaked to
accommodate the move to mobile 2
simplifying the formula from diablo 3
even further no matter which of the 5
classes you pick immortal won't burden
you with managing mana or stamina to use
abilities instead just relying on
cooldowns to balance things out each
ability also only has a single upgrade
path removing the options that diablo 3
gave you to change up their effects this
ultimately gives you a lot less to worry
about but also fewer options to tweak
your build using just your abilities
alone legendary gems that you start
acquiring later in the game do augment
existing abilities while completely
changing others giving you some
flexibility that will be required if you
aim to challenge the game's more
grueling content once you've hit its
level cap of 60. initially the story
itself provides enough momentum to carry
you through your movement between diablo
immortals several hub areas each of
which has a level associated with it to
describe its challenge the structure of
how you move between these areas differs
slightly to the stringent act-based
progression of previous games but it
ties in well with the more mmo-like
nature of gameplay after the brief
introduction your world is populated by
a host of other players letting you
tackle dynamic events and bounties
together other players will seamlessly
join and leave your screen space as they
see fit not requiring you to actively
party up in order to work towards the
same objective although the ability to
do so does exist you can complete diablo
immortal's story entirely alone if you
wish with only end game activities
requiring you to start finding a large
group of players to raid with each story
act is usually bookended by a dungeon
which can be completed alone or with up
to three other players via matchmaking
these are packed with creatures to kill
and climactic boss battles that are a
visual spectacle while also providing
significant loot rewards on completion
this mission can be replayed infinitely
with higher difficulty modifiers to
increase both the challenge and reward
while also providing a good amount of
experience to supplement traditional
progression these along with daily
bounties codex missions and other side
missions are somewhat required after
level 30 when core story progression
grinds to a halt missions start
requiring you to be a certain level to
play them while later game areas will
have monsters far beyond your
capabilities should you venture to them
without the requisite gear and offensive
power these small roadblocks will remind
you diablo immortal is still a
free-to-play mobile game and its
structure has been designed around the
idea of frequent daily check-ins instead
of instantly gratifying long play
sessions it enforces a grind that
prevents you from continuing on with the
story if that's your primary focus
pushing you towards completing daily
bounties a variety of side missions
buried in an assortment of menus that
are specific to both your character and
each of the areas you visit as well as
progressing smaller side stories
none of these are as engaging as the
main campaign especially when most boil
down to traveling to previous locations
and killing a number of enemies you've
already killed hundreds of the paid
version of the battle pass offers more
experience bonuses if you choose to
purchase it which would speed this
process up significantly so the
temptation to pay to bypass the roteness
always feels present when you're booting
up the game and being reminded of the
tasks that await still if you're adamant
not to spend a cent these hindrances
might only delay your progress by a day
at most allowing you to grab new
bounties and their associated rewards in
order to progress where diablo immortals
microtransactions start becoming more
troublesome is in its late game content
and especially so once you've seen out
the main story progression slows
significantly from here which impacts
your ability to continue to subsequent
playthroughs and increases your endgame
paragon level pvp play is also heavily
reliant on some of the best gear and
stat altering gems that the game has to
offer the latter of which can be
purchased through a marketplace that
accepts an in-game currency that you can
buy with real-world money unlike diablo
3's original auction house however sales
cannot be converted back to real money
random loot boxes work into the equation
too although diablo immortal excuse the
actual mechanics of this into something
slightly more interactive elder rifts
like those introduced with diablo 3
reaper of souls generate random dungeons
with enemies and a boss for a brief
enjoyable loot rush immortal changes
this formula slightly with crests of
which different types let you ensure the
base rarity of items you'll be rewarded
with in a way elder rifts are immortal's
form of loot boxes with the odds of good
loot depending on how many crests you're
willing to burn on each run crests can
be earned through play but later start
becoming scarcer you can purchase two
regular crests a day using in-game gold
that you earn through play but only one
legendary crust a month through the same
process it's the legendary crests that
are the most valuable however ensuring
that you'll receive a new legendary gem
during a rift one while regular crests
are only assured to drop runes which
help you craft these same gems these
legendary gems act as modifiers to your
core abilities making them stronger or
changing their effects entirely in some
cases while offering more flexibility in
your builds they're also crucial to end
game play especially if you're planning
to get invested in pvp if you're looking
to play beyond the story and increase
your paragon level legendary gems are
some of the only ways to empower your
characters sufficiently placing a
reliance on them that makes traditional
grinding feel increasingly slow when
chasing them it's clear from this
balance that players choosing to pay for
more crests or those purchasing them off
the in-game marketplace are at an
advantage as you'll not be able to keep
up otherwise late game loop progression
legendary gems and elder rift runs all
matter if you're planning to play diablo
immortal for a long time and invest in
its incoming seasons and paragon
progression and you might be tempted to
stick around given how enjoyable the
core campaign is it's a classic diablo
experience letting you gleefully watch
all your stats increase as hordes of
monsters melt in front of you the power
trip it enables sits up there with some
of the best the series has to offer
which makes the sudden halt in pace
jarring and off-putting but it's still
one that you can enjoy without needing
to dive into the mess of menus and lists
asking you to tap a button to claim a
myriad of rewards day in and day out
given you're comfortable with not being
able to power through it all in just a
handful of sittings
[Music]
without a corpse